Hey look guys my name is Jonah welcome
back to my game edge of the series so
last time we talked about logging and we
actually added a logging library called
SPT logos feet log video - that is link
up there make sure you watch that before
you watch this video today we're gonna
be finally using a build system of sorts
so basically we're going to be using
some kind of project generation library
I guess or program that just generates
projects for us this is something that
we haven't done as of yet there's been
kind of discussion I'm using maybe see
make or something like that because
we've kind of have this problem of we
generate projects and we're gonna talk a
little bit about what that problem
actually is today as well as we're gonna
solve that problem as well so first of
all project generation like why do we
need that why can't we just you know use
Visual Studio and make our projects and
everything's gonna be fine so we can and
that's what we kind of have been doing
up until now but the the big issue kind
of creeps up when we have to deal with
different platforms so what I mean by
that is right now our build kind of
toolset is visual studio on Windows and
that's it so the only kind of project
files we have to deal with is Visual
Studio right we have solution files
where we export files which others
tables host project files all that stuff
is kind of windows I guess
the Windows environment for the hazel
engine right but as soon as we start to
kind of add other platforms like for
example Mac or Linux or even like
Android or iOS right we need to actually
generate project files for our engine
that can be used with a toolset that
will compile those applications for us
all right so what I mean by that is like
we literally need to generate for
example an Xcode project file so that we
can build this for iOS that's a one
example right I mean you know we don't
have to use external Mac to build for
Mac but supposedly like let's just say
that we do right so we generate Xcode
project file so that we can build this
hazal engine on Mac what about Linux
right we might want to generate some
kind of project files for specific IDE
or just make files or something like
that but the idea is we have our hazel
project right but the way that we've
defined what that project is right now
is just through visual studio we've just
said okay these are all of the files the
this project these are all the defines
I'm going to need for example age set
platform windows if we're on Windows
right I've defined what my project
actually is right but I've done that in
Visual Studio and what we need to do is
instead of do that in Visual Studio we
kind of define what our project actually
is what the havel engine actually is in
some kind of other format that can then
be used to construct platform specific
project files or rather maybe even tool
chain tool set specific a project files
okay
so what we're going to be using for that
is something called pre make I'll have a
link in the description of this video to
what that actually is and the github
repository so that you can read about it
the wiki they have is fantastic for
learning kind of about what pre mega
actually isn't what it can do for you
I didn't want to use CMake because I
don't personally like CMAC I think it's
very complicated I think it's very kind
of its it uses like it's only kind of
format for a lot of things and it's just
it's just unnecessarily complicated and
hard to deal with
whereas pre-baked is written in Lua or
like when you write pre make files you
write them in Lua and it's just really
easy to use there's not much to it
I mean we're gonna write a complete pre
make kind of file I guess for the entire
hazel engine right now it's gonna be
really simple it's it's easy to
understand for people who are new to
this and it's very powerful and can
generate project files for everything
that we need okay so it's the idea and
then once we kind of define in kind of
pre max format once we define that in
that arbitrary format we kind of define
what hazel actually is so for example
these are the simple these are the C++
files we need to include these are the
header files we need to include these
are the include directories these are
the libraries we want to link you know
these these are the defines that we want
to use these are the different platforms
of configurations we want to set up
right once we define that in Lua we can
then just run pre make and it will
generate video studio project files for
us or Xcode project files for us or make
files for us or whatever right so that's
kind of the idea of why we want to use
this kind of project generator rather
than just deal with everything
manually because as you can also imagine
we could maintain everything manually we
could make expert profiles Visual Studio
pertinent files every time we add a new
file we add it to both Mac and Windows
but we will have to do that all kind of
manually and that's just a pain this is
much much easier and we'll even make
like a bat file which will just be like
a I mean on different platforms that
would be different but since we're
sticking with Windows for now it'll be a
bat file that we can just double click
and it will just generate everything for
us in like I don't know probably take
like 100 milliseconds a list so it's
gonna be fantastic so without further
ado let's just jump in and set up hazel
with pre Mac okay so the first thing I
want to do is actually just kind of run
this maybe and just see what we actually
get just so that we have like a result
that can kind of work towards so I'll
just wait for this to compile and run
and there we go so we say that we
initialize log and we just plan hello
and then we have a wild for the loop
okay great so that's kind of what the
hazel engine is at this moment so now
let's take a look at pre make so I'll
have a link to this in the description
below but pre make is essentially
available free on github if you look at
the license that it actually comes with
it basically just says that is free for
pretty much everything just as long as
this copyright notice especially
retained so we'll have to actually kind
of download this license text file and
use it so I will definitely save that
somewhere but otherwise we can just go
to releases and then pretty make 5.0
alpha 13 is we're going to use as at
this point I suspect that as pre-made
comes out with new releases we will
simply grab that we'll definitely be
using pretty make five and not pretty
make four even though this is kind of
still an alpha it's still quite stable
and it's been fine in my experience and
it has a lot of features that I actually
want to use so there's the Windows zip
file I'm just going to download that and
that should be nice and simple I think
that will only have an exe file and
that's it so if I copy that Exe file I'm
going to go into my hazal directory I'm
gonna make a new folder called bender so
this vendor folder is different than the
vendor we have in Hazel because this
vendor folder kind of applies to
everything whereas this vendor folder
and hazel is just kind of stuff that
hazel needs that isn't house this is
stuff that the entire solution kind of
needs that isn't house
and inside vendor I'll make a directory
called bin and I'll paste in pre make $5
XE I could even kind of make maybe I'll
make a folder called cremate or
something like that
put premade five in there because I also
have to retain this license file so if I
just hit raw I'm gonna right-click save
as and then save that license I'll text
file in here okay so now I am of course
in in in our actual repository which we
will commit we have pre make five eggs
as well as that license file okay great
so there we go pre make is now in here
all we need is a binary we don't need to
compile it ourselves or do anything like
that that's really all that we need to
do now we just need to create a file
that basically just tells Premack what
this whole hazel project is so that it
can so the premier can then generate you
know the solution files the sandbox bcx
prod file this hazel vc a v6 profile
anything that our project actually means
it will be able to generate so as for a
guide to how to do that again this is
not intended to be a premade tutorial
but inside the wiki here so in pre make
repository they have a fantastic wiki
which you can see has like just a bunch
of stuff including this kind of great
guide to your first script so they
actually write like a save file here
just a little c program that just a plus
hello world and then a pre make script
as they call it which is just pretty
make $5 you can see the name of the file
it basically just says how exactly to
define something as simple as that and
you can say what this does is workspace
just basically means solution for visual
studio so we're creating a solution
called hello world with two
configurations debug release then we're
creating an actual project this will be
like a C or C / disable as project in
this case called hello world which will
be a console app which means it's an
executable there's a target directory
which is where the files will be built
to which files should be included in the
project so basically anything in kind of
child directories recursively that have
header files or save files and then we
can apply certain settings to specific
filters so for just the debug
configuration we're going to apply debug
for example and debug symbols will be
turned on but for release we'll have
and debug defined and optimization
turned on so that's kind of just a
really basic example of how pretty mixed
my work again I suggest you read this
maybe in the future I'll come up with a
more detailed premix tutorial but of
course in this case this is more or less
just using premake in hazel and that's
what we want to achieve right now so
popping over to our hazel directory I'm
going to right click hit new and then
create a new text document which is
going to be called pre make five dot
Laura okay which is as you can see the
same format that they've kind of done
here right and then I'm not really gonna
copy a lot of this I think I'm just
going to type it up myself but we're
basically just going to make I'll drag
this pretty make $5 file individual
studio and we're basically just gonna
make our pretty my koala here so
workspace of course I'm gonna call hazel
okay so this hazel workspace is kind of
this solution you can see it's called
hazel that's what it's going to be the
architecture for this is going to be x64
okay
I seem to be struggling with courts here
basically the architecture is just the
platform that we actually want to deal
with which in this case we have decided
we don't want to deal with 32-bit right
now just x64 and that's it and then for
the configurations of this you can see
that we've kind of got debug and release
which is the default for now but I am
actually going to add a third one so
we'll have our configurations we're
gonna have debug which of course is just
the debug configuration that we are used
to the release one and then I'm also
going to add something called dist so we
might talk about these three in the
future you'll kind of see how they work
maybe in here as well but debug is
basically just full-on just debug code
everything enabled that we kind of used
to develop in release is kind of not
necessarily the release mode that we
kind of order it the release build that
we actually send out to people but it's
just kind of debug but with a lot of
debug information stripped optimizations
turned on but other things such as
logging for example still actually
enabled so it's like a faster version of
debug essentially that will also do less
and then distribution is actually
everything kind of stripped everything
just out complete distribution build
with absolutely no logging or anything
like
that's kind of the idea and we'll of
course see how this works
in the future of this series and then
after that I actually want to create a
project called hazel so this project is
kind of corresponding because it's
called a project and on a workspace it's
kind of corresponding to this hazel
project so basically stuff that we've
put in here into properties such as you
know our preprocessor stuff which you
can see is a chat platform Windows H
that build dll win DLL you know copy
these right now but you know stuff like
that as well as all the files it
includes that's kind of what we actually
want to put into here because this is
our project so what I'll do is first of
all specify the location of this so we
want it to kind of our pre make file is
inside our hazel root directory but you
can see the hazel project is inside a
hazel folder so to kind of specify that
I'm going to type in location hazel and
that'll make sure that everything will
be relative to this path as well as
everything that we like the protocols we
generate will actually be placed into
that path you can see we of course want
these vcx profiles to be inside hazel
and not alongside our solution file now
I need to set the kind that it is so
basically is it like an application
executable is it just a static libraries
at a dynamic library because it's a
dynamic library you would say that it's
a shed Lib because that's the correct
way to specify that it's a dll file
inside pre make shared libraries the
same as a dynamic library and then the
language we're gonna specify is state
boss boss okay cool so now we specified
like a target directory essentially so
where is this going to be output to you
can see we kind of wanted to be Ben and
then debug x64 and then the project name
and all of that so that's basically what
we're setting up here so it's going to
be bin and then what I'm actually gonna
do is because we'll have to reuse as a
bunch of time I'm actually gonna create
a variable here called
outputs directory right which will
basically use a bunch of kind of tokens
that premake supplies us with I don't
know if there's a good
well there definitely is a good page on
tokens which basically just specifies a
bunch of macros so to speak that you can
actually use so stuff like the
configuration name the file like name
the target path the workspace location
all that stuff you can kind of use as
macros the same way that we kind of have
done inside Visual Studio where we've
actually used you know the solution
directory or the platform of the
configuration that kind of stuff right
so what I'm going to do is just kind of
construct my other directory based off
of those things so the first one that
we're going to use here is going to be
doing the build configuration so this
will basically be whether our is debug
or release then I want to include the
system prior set configuration the
system and then I'm going to also have
the architecture this is a little bit
different than what we actually had
because the system is going to basically
say whether or not it's Windows or Mac
or something like that
right because if we just have kind of
debug x64 well that could be on Mac
right and since we're kind of trying to
make this be universal like basically be
cross-platform we actually need to have
multiple kind of system support I guess
so that we actually differentiate
between stuff like that so configuration
architecture okay and that will generate
something like debug Windows x64 which
is what we need and now we'll take that
and we'll append it to this like that
and then we'll also continue here
because we now need the actual project
name so slash and then prj dot name okay
and that is it so we're putting
everything in bin and then like debug
Windows x64 and then hazel that will be
the kind of output directory for our
binaries and now we need to do the same
thing but as we did for in int which is
our kind of intermediates so the way
that we specify that is basically by
just writing obj directory right and
that we've been half an int I think
someone asked why I call this folder
being ins and not something like obj
like object I did that well one of the
reasons
was that the nicely grouped up here so
fine I want to delete these or whatever
they just right there been been in
that's it if I had obj will be sorted
somewhere below
you know hazel in this case and it'll
just be a little bit less kind of
grouped together and a little bit less
clean so that's why I prefer to do it
this way okay and now we can define the
files that we actually want to include
inside here so I'll save files and then
we'll basically just have a list of
files that we want now everything of
course is kind of inside the project
name right so the perfect the project
name is hazel which happens to be the
location here so what I'll do is I'll
say these files are kind of inside
project name and then slash source and
then we'll do a double style which
basically means recursively search the
folders from that folder kind of
downloads right over the child folders
dot H right so H files and CBP files now
if we have like HPV files or dot C files
that's something that we also might
include but since we don't have any of
that right now I'm not going to worry
about that just basically every dot H
file and every dot CPP file that is
inside the source directory should be
included inside here okay and now I'll
also do the include directories so I
think the include directories that we
actually ended up using we're really
just SPD log right so that's what I'll
do for now this will simply just kind of
be I think we had a specific one though
let's just copy it so hazel Vanda hazel
we can keep and then just offender SPL
I'll conclude okay sure so I will say
over here we'll grab a project name a
slash I guess project name slash slash
bad does those non source so proud name
vendor SVT log included that should be
correct because we should be in hazel
vendor hazel vendor and then SPG log
include okay great
cool so there we go that's that we'll be
out front of soul includes directory for
now but if we decide to include other
things obviously as we as we go along we
will just add it to this list
okay so now we can talk about country's
defiance now these are obviously windows
specific defiance so this is a good time
to actually introduce filters so we can
use filters to say that we have certain
project kind of configurations or other
certain kind of program properties that
we only want to apply to like a certain
platform for example so in this case
we'll say if the system is of Windows
then kind of everything else everything
underneath this filter tabs don't
actually matter by the way indentation
doesn't matter at all I'm just using it
here so that it's more readable but
basically anything underneath this
filter until we either reach another
filter or another project or something
only applies to Windows so for Windows
we'll set our CBP dialect to see if I
plus 17 the reason I'm setting this just
for Windows by the way is because in
other for other compiles we actually
might need to have like a specific
compile flag rather than just being able
to arbitrarily set this EVP dialect
because that's not kind of supported by
pre McDonnell compilers the static
runtime will set you on which kind of
has to do with linking the runtime
libraries we want to obviously link them
statically in this case and then what
I'll do is actually create something
called system version here now what I
want to do for this is I'm just going to
copy the version that we have up here
the windows SDK version and just paste
it in here the reason that we need to do
this is because if you don't specify
this at all
then premake will actually generate a
Windows 8.1 Windows SDK version right
which not everyone has installed for
example I didn't actually have this
installed on my laptop and so I had to
manually retarget the solution that's
annoying
so we'll just go with this we might if
there was a way to just change to like
10 dot X low just to use latest I would
do that but I don't think there's a way
so if now we're just gonna leave it on
just the version that I happen to have
installed on my computer just like that
and now finally we can talk about the
defines so these are our three defines
let's copy them paste them into here H
their platform windows H said build DLL
and the
kind of win vol as well which we
probably aren't using anywhere I was go
as far to say we probably don't need it
in fact I might admit it for now that's
just something that was automatically
generated by Visual Studio when we
actually created a new kind of DLL
project I think even though I think we
did create an empty project not sure of
it anyway
yeah when DLL is that used anywhere I
just quickly check the entire solution
it's not so I'm going to omit it for now
and we'll see if that breaks anything
okay and then finally what I want to do
for Windows as well is kind of create a
post build step to Hazel that actually
puts the DLL where we want it to be
because you can see that every time we
kind of built this we had to manually
copy the DLL file from hazel into
sandbox I don't really want to do that
so I'm just gonna add a purpose-built
command that actually does that so the
safest place to add it actually has a
post field command to our actual hazel
project copy is a command that actually
comes with
premie they've got a few I don't know if
first build command will actually be
yeah I guess it will you can see that
the wiki actually has an example of
copying stuff so that's best what we're
going to do so we're going to type and
copy and then we'll we'll copy from the
configuration build target relative path
which is that into dot dot slash bin so
we're going up a directory into the bin
folder and then into the output
directory variable and then into slash
sandbox okay so basically what this is
going to do is just in hazel it's going
to go to the bin directory and copy
hazel hazel dot DLL into sandbox into
the sandbox directory so that we have
alongside there okay next I'm going to
go and create a filter there's going to
be our configurations
debug build up okay so this filter will
kind of only apply to our debug
configuration so what I want to do is
define for the debug configuration ages
that on the support debug okay and also
we're gonna have debug symbols and on
I'll copy this and we'll kind of paste
it two more times for release I'm going
to use Hz release of course optimization
will be turned on so optimize on and
then this one will be our disk
configuration which will have hsf disk
defined and then optimization on it as
well so that's all will do for now to
keep this nice and simple now quick note
when you use a different filter like
this it actually is completely it's only
today it's only this this isn't now
Windows and debug it's just debug if you
want to do both then you have to specify
both of the kind of filter options so
for example what we'll do here as well
set it to kind of use the multi-threaded
library yes that will just save filters
you can see how I've been filled ah
sorry filter but I've actually opened up
a Kelly bracket here because I'm
specifying multiple options here so have
serve basically for Windows and release
as an example we're actually going to
set you know build options /f take for
example which is basically the
equivalent of just going over here into
command line and doing a /m tape of /mt
which in this case it just tells us to
use the multi-threaded runtime library
as seen here okay
but we won't worry about this for now
this that's just an example that we
might come back to in the future
okay cool anyway that's it so that is
our entire hazal kind of configuration
right here I think that's pretty simple
hopefully it's fairly easy to understand
I think I explained it fairly
comprehensively I didn't think there's
much else like I really say apart from
if you don't understand any of it or
some of it then
just referred to premake and the wiki
and maybe just practice by creating your
own syphilis project and then using pre
mates try and generate fast from there
okay cool
so anyway we now need to create a
sandbox project it's gonna be our
sandbox project the location is going to
be sandbox the kind is going to be
console at this time instead of a shared
library language will still be C++ let's
just copy a bunch of these things really
what I could do by the way is just copy
like most of this I think because it's
gonna be fairly simple so I'll copy all
of this
so inside sandbox we have a console app
language will be C++ and target
directory will be the same because we've
used kind of project name and macros
like that we can literally just copy and
paste it when it needs changing files
will have that'll be exactly the same
include directories will be a little bit
different so we do still need that kind
of SP log include here but what we
actually can use or rather what I will
want to use because I think we just
include hazel dot H here kind of by a
compiler a compiler include path because
we actually have you can see hazel sauce
pointing here so what I can do what I'll
need to do is also add hazel sauce as an
include path here under filter system
windows this will basically be the same
of course we need to build the other
thing edge of that platform windows
should still be defined we don't need
this post build command either
configuration debug release and disk
kind of remains exactly the same though
so one thing that we need to define here
that we didn't do of course inside hazel
is the actual link so sandbox need to
needs to link in hazel and all we just
do for that is to type in links and then
the name of the project so Paisley and
that is yet so you can see that pre make
is quite easy and nice to use and we
really don't have anything to complicate
it I don't think here at all okay that's
it we're done so now what I'm going to
do is a few things first of all in our
hazel directory I'm actually going to
delete bin and bin int okay because that
stuff that is a result of compilation so
obviously we should be able to
regenerate that easily I could also
delete the Hazel's illusion file and
also the project files and all that
stuff I'm not gonna bother because
pretty Mac will kind of regenerate that
for us so now all I really need to do is
actually call pre make with this script
file and hopefully everything will work
so I'll open a command prompt in this
directory
I'll type in I think random in remake
and pre make 5xe and then the project
files that I want to generate force so
in other words I want to generate Visual
Studio 2017 but project files so type in
ves 2017
I'll hit enter and we'll see what
happens okay so we attempted to
concatenate a table value um
F name that's great I probably just have
like a syntax error or something like
that so I'll look through this quickly
so one problem that is spotted so far is
that I include to actually be include
directories simply does
so let's rerun that and see what happens
and there you go so unfortunately
sometimes you don't get the best error
messages but checking over that seems to
fix that okay great so I'm like 84
milliseconds we've read read and write
at all of our solutions it's really nice
and fast and so what we have over here
now is brand new kind of hazel solution
file so to kind of further prove this
point I guess what I'll do is I'll
delete all of this including the user
kind of stuff that we have here so we'll
delete all of this and then we'll just
run this kind of pre-make thing again
now instead of me having to every time
we're gonna come at a command prompt and
just type this stuff in here what I'm
actually going to do is make a bat file
so I'll make a new text document
it's just going to be called generate
projects that I'll open this over here
I'll type in
all destroyed hasn't it let's just close
this no I don't want to save changes
let's go back and open this I'm just
going to type in Paul and then this sir
call that and then probably just pause
so that it doesn't close the window
immediately okay so now that I've done
that I can I should just be able to
double click generate projects you can
see it generates everything for us
there's that new solution file I'm just
going to drive that into Visual Studio
here to open the solution and here we
have inner hazel with everything you can
see even generated generated the right
kind of filters for us and you know if
we go into properties for example we
should see the correct kind of output
directory here as well as you know like
this kind of stuff that we've um added
like our include directories and our
defines are all there and also you can
see sandbox references hazel correctly
which looks good so I will set sandbox
here as a starter project and hit f5 and
then hopefully everything will work fine
now the first time it seems that this
kind of copy step fails because the
directory doesn't actually exist yet so
we'll just hit f5 again and it should
work
you can see the copying probably work
now but now we can't open SBT log
because no such file exists I believe
that's coming from sandbox app so it's
probably because we messed up an include
path include directory this specific to
our actual sandbox project so let's take
a look here it's a parrot named inventor
yes that's not gonna work because this
is actually under hazel so hazel vendor
SPD log include should be good so now
let's regenerate our projects we'll just
delete this file gun reload f5 and you
can see that that worked there we are
all done and obviously the dll copying
is working so if we go to bin debug and
then you know sandbox we can see that
dll file gets placed alongside our yes
they file and that everything just
generally themes seems to work pretty
well so you should now be able to just
run that file I'll kind of run this
premade script and actually have this
generate make files or Xcode
everything should be great so that's it
that's a basic kind of introduction to
pre meg and we've set up pretty much to
work for hazel and for sandbox and
basically for our entire hazel project
so I hope you guys enjoyed that if you
didn't hit the like button below and now
this will be used will kind of work on
this pre Mac script throughout the
course of this series because it's going
to be our main kind of project project
generator and I think there is visiting
a way for it to generate actual Samek
files if we really need that so it's
just a really good system that's really
straightforward easy to use and that's
one of the reasons that I've kind of
chosen this I want to give a huge thank
you to all the patrons that make this
series possible you can help support
this series by going Pedro knuckle 4/2
churner you'll get videos of one week
early as well as access to like a
private development branch of this
engine in which like I've already got
like you know a window up and running an
event system up and running like all
that stuff basically as fast as I can
I'm developing the hazel engine kind of
privately just so that I know what to
making these videos and all of the kind
of page wants to support at a 70 I
actually get access to that and in
return also it helped me make these
videos which is really cool hope you
guys enjoy this video next time we're
gonna continue on with our hazel engine
I don't even know what I've got planned
for next time get excited I'll see you
then good bye
[Music]
you
[Music]